you sang and played guitar but I'm just
short stubby fingers it never works
I took one summer of guitar that I
couldn't get it to go oh [__] oh [__]
periscope BAM like a [__] bad
flavor here preacher chin it we're gonna
go back to you scream tonight yeah we
got my man Dean Dorian House to fly a
Jew a lot of [__] things going on
right now
for starters led to the ceremonious you
know why [__] around 200 milligrams whoa
BAM
oh yeah the Stars this is direct one two
three [__] you leads us three just in
training with drop them we're going 800
milligrams right off the [__] bat
tonight you understand me there's no
[__] around here tonight another
Church deemed a Rosie's here yes we got
no time to [__] around right now we've
got that flippers debut I'll mine on
through the night 1980 a masterpiece oh
yeah you got wasted rocks off and don't
matter
answer to the master overture the other
side this tremendous [__] rock brigade
we'll start you off with that while we
set this hash ball on [__] fire what
do you think you're dealing with some
[__] novice it's Tuesday night
[__] turn to a wireless
turntable what a setup Webster the
question is do you know that's great was
a turntable yeah
questions being done dizzy oh this how
we're doing this [__] right here
oh we're gonna get this ready right now
this little party started
listen the one eyed you came by to this
looked at this [__] right here
we're gonna start with a little one
right here this is a little meeting you
up dead
this is some [__] Brown here ash from
Egypt stamp from the Emperor of debt
let's see if this mother [__] long
pipe is Ramage's we're going back to the
[__] 70s on the [__] the old
[__] look at my man [__] don't
Rizzy
yeah look at this the hash is on fire we
blow this [__] out we take it to
the glass deep though right right
that's how I would do it old-school
eighth grade right get out of the
goddamn race so mr. Lisa at to do his
hash get over him though two days from
now [__] Yeah right now look at me
oh yeah sure whatever what's up that
wasn't my car
let's go Lincoln I think yeah this is
old school funk event look at it's still
burning beautifully in there look at
they see the trunk two hat you see the
smoke on the Freddy you don't want that
stale hash in every morning
[Music]
oh [__]
we're going deeper look at still burning
yeah see the cloud and it's different
we don't [__] around them you took
everything else well I got more for you
that's a little baby meteorite [__] hey
open take it off real quick don't do
this at home little kiddies Gally BAM
they did go up we get there in there so
leave that smoke filling up in this yeah
that's clean [__] the smoke right from
Egypt look it's like dripping down the
sides and down this look at the smoke
underside like they're mostly you still
want to sit there and down [__] blow
kerosene and your ones gladly go to town
[Music]
so let's just move yeah that's why I
said he's head he said we've heard this
for a year reason after the bang he
rewrites it because a thousand other
[__] that she's a genius with this
[__] there's all he smokes man every
time I see him his eyeballs a [__]
beat red buff this is get another piece
[Music]
coal-based
take this dad goes right through my
fingers I don't give a [__] I think a
bank safe bet you don't make vision take
a little piece off right here that's a
nice piece
someone said can we burn a star hey
[__] brother stop reading these
[__] stuff let's do a double decker
oh [__] who story rocker a two story
rock I love you wow this is some Aviles
Basement Tapes [__] right there you see
that people watch what happens now
yeah it's a double carbonated [__] go
Zoop
you understand me people yeah while you
sitting at home finger-banging yourself
with the next mine [__] would take it to
the next level
oh [__] super smoke out holy holy give
me that let's all be right there what
yeah yeah he doesn't want a piece of
this means clean and strong but you
don't [__] with this it's just me and
you oh my god with the hashish brothers
tonight
[Applause]
that's it there's a little bit take that
phone join we're taking it to the next
level right here is the real [__] with
this [__] listen people I love you
[__] wrong fine I will [__]
around on the church all these other guy
he he he and we take the hehehe to the
next level we are [__]
one more there you go i dick I'm up yup
yup it's tremendous [__] hash banners
you can't do it that fast let's do it
let's do it right here look he's a guru
my little drew I'm like get to a double
periscope yeah oh [__] I thought Lisa
Ads got a message for you guys
adblock plus I just oh here you are
hi guys go follow me on Twitter and I
just tweeted Adblock Plus apparently if
you use that you're not gonna see ads
and this is brought to you by - this is
real [__] great man I love I told you
[__] earlier we're coming high
and dry tonight and out released in July
at 81 you know it was the weirdest sound
because it came on July and anyone but
it really didn't catch fire - about
December of 81 and then anyhow you went
there and in high school party party you
went if they want anybody they would
have that [__] out one ayah dry last
in my heart for about a year and a half
I played every day and the first [__]
inside his [__] spotless and the
second side is just as good but that
first side would lady strange this show
it's just phenomenal
now [__] yeah and that's it we're just
getting started here
yeah BAM I smoke a little reefer you
[__] get the party started you
know how we do it man it's just a
Tuesday night it I'm happy you [__]
tuned in
[Music]
the fact of this record it's got the
[__] King Pete Willis Hootie Willis
left the band
hey Willis did this album and high and
dry and then left before pyromania which
we also have we listened to a cup from
pyromania another great island that was
released in 83 if you're a music app you
know and you like vinyls we'll bring a
vinyl back at night I do a little
periscope show we get now but a week and
then look at these these are [__] in
great shape that's mean ice pick them up
today by mistake by [__] mistake and
all three of them were there in order
for me atomic records I got Metallica
and justice for all
mint how much seventeen
that's a double record so it was 25 its
original Tomic records in Burbank down
to come on it for [__] for those you
know how do we do it you go over you
smoke the number you go to porno G and
then you walk over to atomic then you
get yourself a nice [__] out for the
dead look at this bad boy here [__]
pyromania Def Leppard 83 first time Phil
Collen on the guitar Mutt Lange is still
[__] producing just a sensational
sensational piece of [__] work here
I'm gonna play a little run off this
sound before we get to church started to
give Lee a little [__] you know
lesson get it together
no no I want you to get to dig you go
you stream ready yeah we're gonna go
what was that
from using it I don't know [__] yeah
this record is smoking I'd love to get
the commercial stuff off this sound but
then it goes into true great [__]
songs it goes into our stage fright too
late for love and die hard the hunter
this is what we're talking about here
[__] Lee already had three
[__] stars you're twenty minutes too
late [__] who you think you're
dealing with here some knowledge some
novel each from the other side here Def
Leppard released two or three albums in
a row I mean they're not Pink Floyd
caliber but this [__] high Romanian
high and dry
listen high and dry is just one of those
[__] hours and we're gonna cover for
you tonight close to close brings down
the song you just stop with the [__]
coffin already who gives a [__] other
times you gonna call up over there you
tryin to [__] thumb over the coop
[Music]
[__] now we got some reefer coming
you're hoping out on me when I'm on fire
oh [__]
yeah
[Music]
fill up your bowls [__] it's that
time of the night
[Applause]
[Music]
baby dress the gear what's up
[__] uncle Joey here
tell : and suck my dick and his sidekick
there's a way better show but main man
Lisa at my main man Vicky [__] sigh
at his assistant and my main man deep
though I don't even oddly meteo then we
got reef where they see stars of debt we
got some [__]
[Applause]
I have no idea something clear off my
nose so I can smell my own [__] farts
in this hammock oh [__] there we go all
the [__] fill this up and get
the party started nice nobody gets their
feelings hurt and it's a Tuesday night
the church is off and running
like I said we're covering high and dry
what's gonna fail the time is you know
how we do it
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
very cozy the American flag we at least
say at our Josie Wells child Frandsen
wheelchairs we are couch
[Music]
right after birth my main man Kevin
you'll be shout out
[Music]
[Applause]
so Liz we're gonna do we're gonna switch
over to the podcast get this party
started we're on Ustream tonight we're
gonna find please follow Lisa at I'm
gonna retweet it right now and I'm gonna
[__] have the adblock basilia we get
music we got all the goodies around I
[Applause]
[Music]
want you know
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's it you bad [__]
we're just here to fill a little holes
in your heart you know [__] it that's it
you don't like the cursing you don't
like to reap them go somewhere else
pull me out with Christians yeah come
look for my phone it's right there I'm
[__] [__] my haha
that's them you know you're [__]
[__] heat a freak without warning my
appetite the sex makes me so horny
listen for this [__] right here
yeah nope too late for love this is
tremendous how many [__] out he was
on fire back in black highway to hell
for those about to rock these [__]
three I am Drive pyromania
[Music]
are you doing over there Zambo you ready
for another star
[Music]
I popped a brownie earlier sure I get
the blood on his Tuesday I went to
acupuncture tell it feel him do it like
a cop that got needle to death
she said she's seen a streamer hello bad
chief come out of my [__] on the
holes
I'm ready Rock oh [__]
[Music]
well it's all about people sit back with
your family smoking some food salutes
and that's it what else you want you a
magic trick you want a [__] recipe I
got none that [__] all I got is love
reefer and hard for you [__] if
you don't want that
what do you know
[Music]
get down at home [__] even if you
gotta go to youtube you get pyromania
fallout put this [__] monster
on this is Pete Willis is first time
right yeah
pyromania this is first off now Phil
Collins from [__] to Genesis bill
downs little [__] blonde that game
pretty badass cat Empire
[Music]
lowly
it's too late too late we go forget that
better bett isn't it too late
oh [__] it's too late is it to stand
there no no no
[Music]
here we go people here we go
it's too late
[Music]
until are you kidding me break out the
[__] syringes over I'm shooting my
toes
[Music]
I still remember snort blow this and the
Lydia's alleyway behind the [__]
house then Adela the one thing with a
[__] eye well it was in the world of
things so we had like early this is one
this is like the third or fourth year
long oh yeah Walker we had one he walks
is only one tape cassette love and I had
this on cassette and I would sit there
like a [__] doing blow cry and listen
to this [__] drinking [__] father's
is tremendous just don't [__] it out
again the winter helicopters bump up
pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
this is another [__] Savage ahead
what's this one death weapon tremendous
tremendous don't you were forcefully
they say it's just another Jam in die
hard the [__] hunter it's time
to break out some more weed you got it
at home I told you once I've told you a
million times break it to your grandma's
medicine drug this is too deep to handle
soap
[Music]
no angel of mercy
I'm sending smoke signals to [__]
Indians tonight for going deep where's
that hashish it's over diehard the
hunter are you [__]
[Music]
oh [__]
wanna be Sahaj people what the [__]
can't walk on one man I'll [__] when I
get pissed off I put my guitar
[Music]
they'll say what the [__]
oh [__] same same effect [__] die
hard
oh [__] let the devil loose [__]
let the pigeons loose
[Music]
these are the rates
oh [__] no sucker oh [__]
[Music]
alright [__] with tapping into
the church right now go to Ustream will
show up with an ad blocker and your life
will change my life should change it to
like [__]
oh [__] it's over break up the Gorilla
Biscuits I'll get back to you
[__] later